everybody says you're good everybody
says you're amazing you did you change
the whole world very good if you are
beating your mother hitting your mother
who cares if I went to these people and
said you know this bag he's so amazing
this charity such a good guy yeah but
Joey beats his mother are you telling me
not a single person will come and say
this guy's a good man you say I don't
care how many people he helped if you're
beating your mother and swearing at your
mother to me you're a bad person
now imagine the one who's trying racing
against Allah so that's the reason why
well you see why good people go to hell
the definition is who do you define as
good at sir
I give Salam to my people in Bangladesh
Salaam to the people of Marrakech it's a
sacrifice but it's a small price to pay
for all the rewards will came from my
love
so I'm making brother and sisters hope
you guys know well inshallah before we
start the video bonuses don't forget
with your support and help it's how we
bring with videos to genre
it was financial support if you can
share this video it will mean so much to
us so we can carry on doing this
inshallah at Salaam let's get straight
into inshallah okay so basically you
know this is not phenomena but know
people ask this question or you know
what why do good people go to paradise
you have friends on mother Turner's huh
you know oh hell yeah let's say why do
good people go to hell yeah so what they
say that people that mother Teresa you
know she was a good person you know are
you telling me that she's gonna go hell
or not people come and see it is that
for example some people in my family
they come and say look I'm a good person
to people you know I I help this person
I'm good to my neighbors I do this I do
that you know are you telling me I'm
gonna go help
where does it's like what do we
understand what would you say is
problematic when somebody comes and ask
you this question how would you apply to
them I think the first thing you have to
understand is that a foreign Islamic Co
a logical perspective the everything
links back to the attributes of God
and I think that's a very important
starting point as Muslims who believe
Allah God is most merciful most gracious
most merciful or knowledgeable or wise
most just so anything that happens as a
result of his treatment of a particular
situation must in by necessary reality
be the perfect thing that happens to
where his there he's dealing with so for
instance if he's dealing with us as
human beings he can never oppress us
that's not possible that's the first
starting point that's our theology now
how do we explain that because a lot of
people will say yeah I'll say for
instance calling me nice the house in
pick up actually I'm just actually a
film in know that for example are you
are you putting limits on God that he
could
kind of process what if you choose it on
pressors okay now if if there's a god
who chooses to oppress the people and
yeah yeah ask yourself the question
answer to this would contradict can't
have a god with contradictory attributes
okay because if his attribute is meant
to be a just God then it can't have
anything that contradicts that that
would contradict his attributes right so
the point we're making is this is that
the problem this is what they call it
was a problem of evil
atheists usually make this kind of claim
how could have god this omni-benevolent
omniscient have create evil in the world
hmmm there's lots of problems with this
is it there's a presupposition from
their perspective that evil exists
atheists don't even believe atheists
objectively exists in the first place
many of them I mean Bertrand Russell
Jacques Derrida
you know in each all of those
individuals don't even priests they
don't even mention they mentioned that
evil doesn't exist as an actual
objective reality right yeah so for an
atheist to ask well how could evil exist
how could how could they be so much even
in the world
for example I'm just saying and that
would be a contradiction in terms it
first have to go and prove evil exists
no well do that's one point another
point would be this
another point would be that actually as
Muslims we believe that Allah tests
human beings yeah it's as human beings
so he puts them in a situation where
there's good forces of good and forces
of evil and then they have a autonomous
ability to make a decision between good
and bad and as a result of that they
will either be going to heaven or hell
as according to the judgment of God so
he would never fall short in judging the
situation to be whatever it is meant to
be and that's why I lost my entire
whenever he talks about in the Quran
whenever he talks about people going to
hell he says for example jay-z and with
her car then this is a a recompense
which is appropriate which is perfectly
appropriate so it's not something which
is inappropriate something which is well
deserved well deserved yeah it's
absolutely well deserved it's a
recompense right
now we're not saying that everyone is
not Muslim and we've done videos on this
before this is gonna necessarily always
just going to help yeah we're saying
that they're sent conditions that have
to be met before someone goes to
Hellfire
okay so for example if someone's a
non-muslim but I've never heard the
message of Islam yes we can't say this
person is going to hell so Mother Teresa
we don't know what exposure she had to
Islam Allah says in the Quran in chapter
17 verse number 15 he says when I
couldn't my Olivia had done a battle so
we were not going to punish them until
we send a messenger to them and so the
so the other way the scholars say that
that means to say that we can't we
cannot say that a kafir even if he dies
upon sure can cover yeah he's going to
hell unless we're aware that they have
gone through that exposure and even then
a low-volume we say fully but we do we
won't agree that scores would agree that
but the acid is that the disbelievers
yeah so we say okay there are the
originates that yeah this means this
type but what they knew they didn't know
that's between the members exactly so we
can't we can't say that us harbor
generals have enough is it going to have
one because they if they have not heard
about Islam fully or they haven't it
destroyed version of Islam is different
to fit on Abu jahil yeah okay so that's
one thing another thing is really really
really important the question could be
asked say okay we said it is in exact
exactly appropriate retribution going to
the Hellfire for example now we've been
told to the Quran that the Hellfire is
an eternal punishment yes so someone
might argue that how could it be an
eternal punishment and the sin was not
eternal yes so let me give you an
example right so someone might say so if
someone was a disbeliever for 60 to 70
years yeah why is it that they're going
to the Hellfire for ever why shouldn't
they be going to the Hellfire for 60 to
70 years like nothing in the earth how
would you answer I have a wife is
correctly.i one brother Abdullah
andalusia had a very good discussion
with him alaikum a really good point one
time I have to give him credit
yeah it's all about how you change
situations or you can do something this
one second takes literally 2 3 seconds
but the but the the sin is so horrific
yeah that the judgment on that
individual was much worse don't give an
example right how long does it take to
kill someone good plan to get a knife
and to stab someone and killed him takes
three or four seconds it could take you
to shoot someone the head takes one
second yes alright so if someone takes a
second to shoot someone in the head
we're not gonna punish them for one
second though because the idea is now we
have to answer the question what is [ __ ]
because when you understand the
magnitude of [ __ ] is when you start to
appreciate the the reasoning for the
punishment because silk is associating
partners with god it's worse than
shoeing anyone in the head okay and if
you're doing that for all of your life
then the recompense of that is the worst
of the worst and also just stay there
just in a break on that point I would
have answer in this way so it is that
yes they must okay 70 years he's been
doing that yeah but the question is this
who said that they would have done
something otherwise they would've made
me favor on earth for a million years
they put the words Allah say yes and if
we send them back yeah they would have
done the same thing so 70 years that
means a las basis it was tested you we
know you're gonna come and do this for
the rest of you it's a good point very
good point in fact yes yes that's a
correct point because yes as you said
this stuff is in the Quran honey may I
follow behind there become in in Chicago
mwah amen - what kind of logic what kind
Allah what can a lot of shakin on Halima
but what is Allah gonna do with your
punishment mmm Allah does not need to
punish you for any reason there's
another misconception that's made out of
your actually Allah is punishing the
person because he needs to punish the
person
no Allah answers that misconception but
I say what is Allah gonna do with
punishing you in Shikata Moorabbin - if
you are thankful and you believe what
can allah who share killin anima and
allah is thankful and he's knowledgeable
and look at the two things I've been
mentioning in this verse
wellcan allah ho shark iran Alima Allah
is thankful for anything that you do
a lot is waiting for the moment where
you thank him so he can thank you I was
waiting for the moment where he well you
turn back to him so he can so he can
guide you Allah says in the Quran in
that Elena and Hoda that certainly upon
us as the guidance and you know Subhan
Allah Allah says Allah and him in your
share
Allah guides whoever he wants and the
wedding in Arabic is unbelievable that's
why I letting the Arabic is very
important well love weirdy menya share
Allah guides whom he wants but the
Arabic has two meanings one of them is
that Allah guy - allowance to God okay
and the other meaning is that Allah
guides whoever wants to be guided Wow so
what's both it works reciprocally yeah
right it literally works both ways so
you want to be guided I'll know once a
day if you want to be guided along like
you that is the promise of Allah so
Allah Tala and that's why Allah says for
it s Teleca I bear the and if anybody
would even our to die that I'm that if
my slave asks about me tell them I'm
near or doesn't say I am near he says I
am Nick I answer the corner of the cool
caller when he calls I did that call it
that has to be a Muslim doesn't have to
be a Muslim it could be a Muslim can be
a disbeliever it could be anyone so the
point is this is that the reason why the
Hellfire is such a painful punishment
it's because the sin that is that is
done in order for one to go to hell
is such a major sin okay now let me stop
me that by you telling this people open
if you call them second now you're
explaining why a good person ends up in
hell let's come to the origin of the
question is this what are they good okay
good good good let's come to the main
phone cuz some of my say okay yo you're
telling me this the reason why it was
the hell yes how person go to hell what
do we define this good this is very key
this is the crux of the matter
if I give charity to the whole wide
world yeah if I give charge to the whole
wide world why am I gonna go help let's
say I'm worshipping a cow I'm giving I'm
helping everybody everybody knows me
look I never seen you help me to change
my life but I'm worshipping a cow why am
I going oh my good okay here's the thing
here's the thing let's put religion to
the side okay just bridging to the side
let's ask a very interesting
philosophical question okay how do we
how do we
extrapolate value from human action in
other words the question is how can you
determine that given charity is a good
thing or that killing someone is a bad
thing and how do we hierarchic how do we
hierarchically put things in order of
this is good this a second good this is
third good etc it will be subjective I
would say to be honest to me helping and
Aunty is better than helping this person
so it'll be totally subjective right we
have to understand that for us we have
an epistemology that which is better
right that which is good to that which
is better or that which is bad to that
which is worse so when we start using
comparatives and superlatives this is
better this is best we have a reason for
doing that because for example we know
that lots of panel Tallis is not the run
that here you know in the Lohr lay off
through why you shocker be here firm I
do know that I can reassure that Allah
does not forgive that someone does [ __ ]
with him and he forgives whatever
whatever else to whoever he wants so for
us the highest biggest sin is [ __ ] which
is association of partners we've gone
why because in terms of the rights of
human beings who should even beings give
their rights to first for us the
relationship between man and God is the
most woman ago it's the most important
relationship yeah is the most important
relationship right okay so if that
relationship is not justice has not done
to that relationship then that has the
most severe ramification also for
example let me give an example to put it
in in human terms if you are rude to
let's say your age right miss your
teacher and your mother will use a
mother okay and they see I beat them
swear it my mom okay if you reach your
mom yes if your roots your mother yes
yeah would you say is it's bad or worse
than being maybe rude to someone online
in the comment section it's worse being
too rude your mother why why she's right
what's the other guy done for me okay so
good you've been able to using your own
kind of rationality say that
subjectively in your opinion here being
rude to your mother
it's worse than being rude to someone
the comment sections up we don't know
this person this is as fast as I you
don't know we're saying let's apply that
same principle why do you think your
mother deserves all that respect because
she's done X and y&z foo she's the one
who you know she was pregnant with your
shoes she gave birth to you she might
have raised you all these things now
we're saying if the measure by which
you're determining value of something is
how much someone has given you then
who's given you more than Allah right
Paul if you believe if you believe in
that allows the one who created you and
he's sustaining you and he's giving you
breath in his giving your mother and
give you your mother is giving you you
know everything that you're doing
whether it be consciously or
unconsciously whether it be whether it
whether it be you know with or without
you whatever everything everything Allah
has given you hmm every human being has
something to thank Allah Spanish I love
or if you believe in Allah and that's
the point the conditional here is
important if if you don't believe in
Allah then let's even imagine you don't
believe in your mother because you might
argue I've never seen a lot well you
know I've seen your great grandmother
you might I've never seen your mother
but the point is this is that point I'm
trying to make here is that if we're if
we're basing on how much has been given
to you then the value of what Allah has
given to you cannot be cannot be
measured how much yeah it cannot be
measured if you count the blessings of
Allah you won't even be able to count
them as the Quran sense right yeah so
the point I'm making too is if that is
the case then the transgression against
Allah must by definition be the worst
kind of the transmission must-buy and
the punishment therefore must be the
worst kind of punishment and on the
flipside of that to be fair on the flip
side of that compliance obedience and
submission to Allah must be the best
kind of action it's far enough so beasts
let me get some notches above assistance
it's very up put in a nutshell everybody
says you're good everybody says you're
amazing you did you change the whole
world very good if you are beating your
mother hitting your mother who cares if
I went to these people and said you know
this Bank he saw amazing this charity so
she could go here but he beats his
mother are you
not a single person will come and say
this guy's a good man you say I don't
care how many people to help if you're
beating your mother and swearing at your
mother to me you're a bad person
now imagine the one who's trying listen
against Allah so that's the reason why
what do you say why good people go to
hell the definition is who do you define
as good exactly you're defining it as
all he helps is ok very good
when he helps the people you praising
what am i this will be in the hood yes
so been on the support our Christian now
who do we define as the good people who
are the good people I was once on a
binge that tsurara stop verse 35 my
response Allah says in mostly Mina while
mostly Marty well mummy Nina what
monatti well colatina well carnot aunty
was saw the key never saw the RT was
sorry Nina wasabi arathi well Kashia
well kashi ah t well mata satte bikina
well Mutasa ducati was saw Amina was
sorry mati
well happy Dina Fallujah home well happy
that he was there Karina Oaxaca theorem
well the karate
lahu lahul McPhee Raton what a jalan
edema allah saying indeed the muslim man
the muslim men and the muslim woman the
believing men and the believing woman
the obedient man an OB the woman the
truthful man and the truthful woman the
patient man and the patient woman the
humble man and the humble woman the
charitable man on the charitable woman
the fasting man and the fasting woman
and the man the men who guard their
private parts and the woman who do so
and the men who remember allah much and
the woman who do so for them allah has
prepared forgiveness and great lord
you'll say your try and bring both sides
of the story now yes yeah because you
know it's not on health I look there's
so what is a good person
yes so this in this verse clearly tell
us yes yeah absolutely man
and you know another there's so many
personal Quran for example lost for
analysis or well absolutely mouselina in
lamo bashira don't want to read that
Allah does not send the the prophets
except for senders of glad
things and then senders or and Warner's
as well as most usually in the Quran the
positive comes first before the negative
in other words not tidings yeah glad
tidings comes first moves in it so we're
not saying that you know there anyone
who lets go to hell this and we're not
starting with that kind of message with
it it's part of our religion right yeah
but there's always a balance in the
Quran between how much heaven is being
mentioned how much I was being mentioned
and the point here is really interesting
actually because this verses fertilize
ever and a loss of pan or Diana does not
need to mention Muslim anyone mostly met
because the word mostly mean it includes
men and woman anyways okay right but
he's using it here for emphasis that
certainly men women men women men women
and all these different things so he
this is showing you the inclusiveness of
Islam that anyone whether it be a man or
a woman or from any tribal place or
country or whatever it may be anyone
who's looking to come back to allah
subhanaw taala
allah has prepared for them more
filipino general not even his preferred
he's prepared for them forgiveness and a
great reward told robbing the sisters to
be or not sure what we've covered here
today was in detail what we define is a
good person now that is very clear to
you if somebody comes to ask you this
question you can install the answer them
in that way to me alone and long be I'm
sure this was from the house with me
about Mohammed II job initially you guys
are benefited and understood shared with
your friends and family may Allah bless
you guys don't forget if you can help us
and support us on the link below
that's inshallah and also do shape of a
MIDI job genres Allah with amazing
videos to next time Salaam alaikum WA
Rahmatullah Mercado